this is a psychological game about being
shut inside which i think is something
that we can all relate to whether we
like it or not
[Music]
this game deals with themes of
agoraphobia isolation and self-doubt
inspired by the author's personal
experiences with depression player
discretion is advised
that seems pretty clear
hello
welcome to the game
if you can call it that
here's where i should probably make
introductions explain how things work
you know how it is
but you seem smart
i'm sure you can figure it out for
yourself
um but maybe not
for keyboards use the arrow keys to move
okay to confirm or interact with objects
press space or z okay
cancel press escaper x and if you want
to use your current item try shift
honestly
that was pretty exhausting you'd better
have remembered all that
i'm not telling you again
anyway
it's xxxx o'clock it's porn o'clock
get out of bed
okay
hello
come on then
it's time to get up i'm trying to
or not
you could always stay in bed i suppose
if that's what you really want so
what'll it be i'll snooze i know you
want me ah
i'll snooze
okay well if you change your mind just
press space at a or get started surely
you can't stay in bed forever
well god damn it now i gotta because
i've been challenged and i never backed
down from a challenge
ever
oh dear the shelf collapsed
all that heavy wood crushed your spine
completely
oh okay
it always was a bit wobbly
you probably should have fixed it by now
you probably should have gotten out of
bed by now too
don't worry try again tomorrow
oh
[Applause]
thanks guys
why not i'll try again i'm not gonna
give up that's the easy way
hello
get me out of this bed get up
hello
there that wasn't so hard was it by the
way you might want to get changed put on
some proper clothes maybe a pair of
shoes something a bit less
sweaty
just head over to the wardrobe when
you're ready and if you need to save
your progress you can set yourself some
reminders on the alarm clock next to
your bed after all you have a busy day
ahead right
bed there's a lump in the mattress
is it that time already
i'm trying to use it
inventory nothing options interesting
okay
[Music]
laundry
the drawer is jammed shut
your computer's plugged in
what i feel little
snippets of like presentable
presentable liberty in this game
there's a flashback
okay
so
about getting dressed i thought that it
was space or z to interact but
no z was
no x's
menu but i thought
[Music]
oh pajamas are comfortable but not
exactly practical get changed
i'm gonna get dressed
i wanna take initiative
ah
that's better much more presentable your
hair needs brushing but you need a
hairbrush you should probably have a
bite to eat too you look
malnourished
oh and wash your face also your breath
stinks okay really lay it on me doc come
on give it to me give it to me the list
is endless really you don't seem to take
very good care of yourself but
congratulations on getting dressed at
least anyway hurry up you have a busy
day ahead and it's already getting late
head outside and get some fresh air but
you told me all the different things
that i needed to do which was like wash
my face and brush my teeth and fix my
stink
can i
there isn't anything useful on the
computer but you're trying to beat your
high score on battle kittens 4 super
force
play some video games
just one
oh no
[Music]
i think i lost
oh
no
you didn't beat your high score
oh
oh but hey
the top one's jam shot something inside
must be blocking the mechanism
i thought i had a busy day
the washer hamper is well over capacity
bolting slightly under its tremendous
weight dirty clothes spill out
everywhere from the top the smell is not
good
well nothing to do about that
can't possibly do anything
alarm clock's slowly blinking on and off
it's already getting laid how
embarrassing just give yourself some
alarms
well i meant to save this before but i
guess it's too late for that should i
make my bed getting pretty dirty there's
a weird smell and a big suspicious lump
in the mattress makes it hard to get any
sleep still a mess though you must have
some pride make the bed
why bother yeah you're probably right
who cares
i mean i don't even make my own bed so
that doesn't speak too low
half filled with miscellaneous rubbish
most of it looks like junk food but you
can't quite see all the way to the
bottom rubbish through the bin hell yeah
rum is through
that's what i always wanted to do for my
own trash can congratulations you found
more rubbish would you like to take some
with you
yes
thank you really absolutely 100 thank
you
fine
whatever you need i'm sure it will come
in handy eventually obtained rubbish
thank you thank you very much
some wrappers tissues old food etc you
have absolutely no idea why you're
holding this
it looks awful it looks terrible glad i
have that
that's odd the door is locked you
remember seeing the key around here
somewhere have a look around maybe you
can dig it out oh but i just went
through the track guess i gotta go again
oh
no oh rum it's true
congratulations you found more rubbish
great all right is this big suspicious
lump actually a key
make the bed ah
but why though why would i do that it's
probably hidden in there
all right fine i'll make the bed no yes
no yes no yes
no okay turn on a light oh that's
helpful
oh that's much more helpful i don't like
the flicker though all right i'll make
the damn bed
it's probably in the bed
[Music]
eh you can't be bothered
what's the point ah come on
i actually wanted to
whatever fine
whatever fine where did my key be
underneath the bed small metal key okay
not sure how it got there okay i have it
i did the thing
finally
i can go on my way
oh
use the key i remember how to use items
i remember
shift
unlock the door can i hold on to like
the rubbish
excellent
loved it user no no no
yes won't do anything it's a pile of
rubbish you still don't know why you're
carrying this round well i'm gonna hold
it in my hand and you can't stop me
because this is what i wanted and i
chose this
there's no use for this key now you
should throw it away
should i
should i
no
i will hold on to it
what
countless shards of red hot glass shred
my face you're totally blinded and spend
the next few hours bleeding to death in
agony
there must have been a power surge or
something but don't worry
what
[Music]
oh
well god damn it the first like 10
minutes of me fumbling around my own
room was like just the basic tutorial i
forgot that this is kind of a horror
game did i mention that that's why the
lights are red
oh yay it's dark the lights are acting
up
two plug sockets on the wall
loud buzz
all right plug is falling a piece slight
gap with a fitting mesa wall looks like
something's trapped inside wedged
awkwardly behind the plug but you can't
reach it
let's pull the plug
i'm dead aren't i
for a split second you feel a searing
heat of over 200 volts of electricity
surging through your body well that's
not very much luckily before your head
can really process the pain your heart
stops completely you're dead in seconds
you talking amps because it's the
amperage it'll kill you all right you
don't even have time to reflect on your
questionable decision-making
capabilities what part of you thought
that that was a sensible oh i'm sorry
pulling the plug out of the socket was a
bad idea oh i'm sorry
whatever [ __ ] dick bag shut up shut
up shut up electricity is dangerous uh
yeah which is why i was trying to unplug
it
idiot
i'm not dumb you're dumb
okay switch it off
there we go that's better small table
with a lamp and a notepad something's
written in the notepad but it's too dark
well damn you
damn you to hell
my bathroom let's go wash my face
[Music]
the pipes are groaning they must be
blocked
that's probably not the only reason
bathtub is thick with damp grime looks
like it hasn't been used for an
embarrassing number of days the plug's
missing but there's still a shallow pool
of black liquid at the bottom now for
some reason there's a screwdriver wedged
into the shower head you're no plumber
but you get the feeling it's not
supposed to be there remove
it does look important and probably i'm
gonna get deluged in an avalanche and a
deluge of black ooze
i got a screwdriver
oh no
there's bugs coming out of the shower
the tap is spewing thousands of black
giant bloods they gleam and arrive with
savage hunger probably the second most
disgusting thing you've ever been in
your bathtub
the first being me can i take a poop
stench coming from the toilet is
overpowering but unfamiliar some kind of
rot that ain't my poop the toilet bowl
is a lot deeper than it should be it
just goes down and down there's
something trapped further
it's hard to see through all the dark
murky liquid reach inside
god yes
oh no
before long the room is completely
filled with insects they crawl all over
you inside and out you're not sure what
these things are but they managed to
strip your skeleton bare in minutes i
forgot about the bugs
i thought that they were just gonna be
happy in the bathtub and that i didn't
need to leave the bathroom immediately
great good try again tomorrow yeah of
course of course thank you i'm gonna
dive straight into the toilet
yes please
reach in as far as you possibly can
until the disgusting toilet fluid reach
past your shoulder your arm is just long
enough to grab hold of something that
feels like some sort of long plastic
tube but it's stuck tight you don't know
how much more you can take stinks so
much you're starting to feel dizzy keep
pulling pull it hard
pull it hard
update plunger ah
you will never get that smell out of
your head you might want to take a
shower or three nope no time for that
i've got a plunger now something
shattered in the mirror it's so cracked
and filthy that you can't see your
reflection although i suppose it might
not be such a bad thing i mean let's be
honest
okay rude you're not good looking okay
well
i disagree
and shut up
it's an old-looking photograph you don't
remember where it's from or what it's of
is that a face
god i hope not
i really hope not
plunger use a plunger yeah sure why not
and a few tugs you feel something in the
drain come loose
[Music]
what i have a door handle now uh
if i grab the screwdriver i believe i
can run right
yeah yeah sure yeah i got it
it's fine
i'm out of here oh
oh oh
the handle oh no oh no oh no no nope
nope nope nope
yep yep yep
oh no oh oh no no no no no no no no no
well
that was a close call let's not go back
in there again yeah let's not let me go
save because that seems like something i
should do after all this trial and
tribulation your bedroom you feel safe
here i probably shouldn't
i bet i should not
i didn't think that death would be
looking for me around every corner in my
own home
okay let's try that again with less
death this time old photograph you think
you remember some of the figures in the
photo but when you try and recall any
details you feel overwhelmed the frame
is stuck to the shelf with grime you'll
need something flat to pry it off
is this a
flat-headed
screwdriver sure give the photo a few
good pokes but you're mostly just making
dents in the frame okay
some unfamiliar pictures on the shelf
you don't recognize any of these
photographs who is this i don't know
well that looks bad
let's go down oh
it's hard to tell but it seems like the
stairs have been somehow torn to pieces
the darkness is thick here you can't see
the bottom looking down there for too
long makes you feel sick you don't
remember how it happened you don't even
know what's going on in the first place
regardless the front door is down there
you'll have to find a way down if you
want to go outside if only there was
some way of measuring the distance still
a jump from this height wouldn't hurt it
shouldn't hurt too much
yeah let's go for it come on it can't be
that bad this has got to be the easy way
out
they're trying to trick me
ow
i'm probably fine how strange
that was a much bigger fall than you
remembered just how far down does the
series go there's certainly a ground
floor around here somewhere your mangled
corpses smeared all over it by the way
that wasn't a very impressive job okay
you're being a little rude and
antagonistic i'm trying my best
but don't worry try again tomorrow yeah
uh-huh i get that
[Music]
yeah yeah
i'm dead
okay hopefully i'm back here what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna throw the rubbish
down i bet that's what this is for
rubbish
yeah i'm gonna it's but i throw it down
to gauge the distance
fine whatever screw you i hate you i
hate you
what if i used the screwdriver on this
yes it's a good thing you already turned
off the power because sticking metal
objects into plug sockets isn't usually
the brightest idea
go to hell and shut up i'm very bright
hold the plug
well with all your might but the plug
won't budge at all somehow fused into
the socket and the screwdriver didn't do
anything i guess it didn't
okay how about the plunger
surely i can plunge this
oh yeah plunger for unplugging drains
not lamps
shut up oh
yeah they won't bite
all right that was obvious
the overwhelming force of a thousand
hungry insects pressing against the door
knocks you to the ground you're not
exactly sure what these things are but
this
well all right okay well i'm dumb i get
it i'm dumb yeah okay all right i get it
all right okay maybe you should hold all
right i get it okay
okay fine
the hell was that oh
attic
[Music]
door to the plant room
the plant room is this the [ __ ] jar
this might be only acceptable the other
right oh i think it's just a vase
comfortable looking armchair there's a
slight groove that looks like it would
fit you perfectly
oh yeah have a break
i can't imagine how this would kill me
[Music]
huh it's nice i guess
but it's missing something
[Music]
okay
you could do with more decorations i
guess that's a hint okay
large wooden crate covered with duct
tape but barricaded
what
screw screws
i have a screwdriver
you managed to remove the screws from
the lid but it's still securely fastened
to the box
what do i need like are you telling me i
need a crowbar or something ah
all right fine
door has been haphazardly nailed shut
with thick wooden planks they've clearly
been here for a while they're rotten
with damp and decay whatever's behind
this door you must be trying pretty hard
to forget about it
yeah okay
is this uh is this house all symbolism
for my mind is that what we're dealing
with here
because uh the psychological thing seems
to be the angle that we're going at
sunlight
well that's nice strange plant a healthy
little sprout there's a small plant
sitting inside a clay pot you don't
recognize it it's enjoying the light but
it looks a little dry okay so it needs
some water
i can piss on it there's a metal
watering can sitting on the table it's
splattered with rust it stinks like old
dam pick it up you know it let's get wet
i don't like that i'm saying that
obtain watering can great if only i had
a working plumbing system i would be
able to water that plant and also that
looked like blood on the walls
which probably a problem so i clearly
can't go back in there
what do i have
with a seemingly endless supply oh there
was water in it
oh well i don't think it'd be a good
idea to try to water that plant with
this stuff
but here we go anyway
okay
sure
sploosh
you gently pour a healthy dose of water
onto the plant the soil is a rich dark
brown hopefully it will start to grow
soon you should check up on it later
okay i wonder if i can use the
screwdriver to pry open my desk
i bet i can
i bet i can i bet i can or plunge it i
could plunge it
you blindly plunge the screwdriver into
the tiny gap and jiggle it around until
the mechanism springs loose looks like
there was a usb cable stuck in it
obtained usb anything else in there i
really don't seem to own many things
well fine then what could i possibly do
with a usb cable what about this
trying to insert the cable into the plug
socket it does nothing it doesn't even
fit stop it
well
okay there's got to be a way to fix this
right watering can
water and electricity are not a very
good combination
i'll be the judge of that once i
actually judge that so let me judge that
ooh wait wait wait wait wait wait use
the key because it said throw it away
right
yeah nothing to unlock here but you've
already left the bedroom you probably
don't need this key anymore throw it
down the stairs yeah get rid of it get
rid of it get rid of it
that's odd you didn't hear it hit the
bottom just how far down does the
staircase go
well apparently very far
and now i know that
but also i don't have that key anymore
so that's a problem
i wonder if that plant is done yet are
you done
and recently watered the soil as a rich
dark brown well that's
lovely
you could maybe loosen some of the
sticky ground with a bit of water but
that would risk ruining the photo
completely ah whatever
whatever what if i pour water down there
minecraft style and then i'd be able to
fall all cushioned like
huh
are you gonna grow the staircase back oh
shut up shut up shut up with your stupid
face shut up
shut up maybe i should play some video
games i bet if i play some video games
it would pass the time it would cause
that plan to grow and then i would be
able to come back and get the plane
where i need to be
but i didn't beat my high school but i'm
outta getting close
and that's all that matters steady
progress over a long period of time and
then i'd be able to do something
that's fine that's fine that did pass
the time
oh
damn it okay there's got to be something
with this plug right
this plug is usable two small screws
holding the plug together yes little
awkward but you probably get them out
yes
yes dismantle it
who needs a computer
i do
i need a computer you take out the
screws and the plug pops open now these
tiny useless bits of metal were keeping
it together you'll never know inside
there's a small fuse it seems to be
working just fine infuse
okay good
now i have that and i've lost my
computer but that's okay because i need
to do this
yeah
plug definitely has enough power already
oh come on
where else would i be using a fuse
plunger
[Music]
if only i could get it wet
interesting
that's not where my brain would have
gone for this but uh okay
i'm gonna get it wet
this does not seem like the right
approach
you douse the dry crackled wood with
water giving the lid a smooth damp sheen
now i'll
plunge it use a plunger yeah
that makes sense
all right
you fasten the plunger to live and
manage to painstakingly heave it open
it's completely empty inside what a
ridiculous waste of time
good
climb inside oh
[Music]
sure
i'll do just that i'll climb inside the
box
great
i'm in a box
it's more comfortable than you thought
there's even room to shut the box
completely close the lid you know it
baby
shut me in why
i don't know but i spent all this
trouble opening it so i'm gonna close it
at least there's barely any room to move
at all after a while you start to feel
different
what
this doesn't feel right head back out
peace and quiet
beautiful glorious peoples and quiet
okay i suppose we can just wait here
then
[Music]
use he's a fusion yeah it's black in
here without any light those items won't
be of much use you can barely even move
it's getting difficult to breathe trying
to mess through
there's no room there's already
[Music]
okay
breakout fine i'll break
[Music]
i don't know why i don't just open the
lid
oh
you know that may have been the
strongest feat of physical strength
you've ever managed it was also
definitely your last as you tear your
way through the lid more and more shards
and splinters of dusty old wood pierce
your flesh lining the crate with your
blood it's a gruesome painful and
slippery death but don't worry try again
tomorrow
[Music]
i did it i'm the best
you're not breaking out of this coffin i
don't know why it was a coffin in the
first place how did i get sealed in
there so good that it killed me
also what was even the point of the
whole box thing
uh you know what i'll climb inside
but then i'll get out
okay you like that wait was it like shut
it and then get out yeah there was
something about like i feel changed
start to feel different it doesn't feel
right and back out time to go
oh no it's locked
oh dear the lid's stuck how on earth did
that happen whatever the case it doesn't
seem to be budging and it's far didn't
okay there must be some item that when
you get in here you're supposed to it's
it's a little counter-intuitive but it
don't make too much sense but i'm not
i'm not gonna question it too much it's
fine so oddly enough i'm still missing
something
oh hi
hello the strange pants are sitting
inside the clay pot it's going to a
healthy size it's enjoying the light but
it looks a little dry
okay
i'll water it again gently pour healthy
dose of water
okay well i guess it's going to get
bigger
but i don't know how long it's going to
take for me to get back to that
but there's got to be something else
here i thought that i thought that there
was going to be the oh of this box
it's messing with me okay
not the cable runs not nearly enough
room between each board all right fuse
time baby
don't be ridiculous well you're
ridiculous
there's a usb cable put the cable around
then give it a tug that's still stuck to
the shelf pull any harder and the whole
frame could collapse
okay so what do i have that's delicate
enough to get that off
wait usb cable on the staircase
oh
there we go not sure if it'll hold your
weight but it certainly seems sturdy
enough all right let's do it let's do it
let's do it descend
oh my
goodness
well that's disturbing
i don't remember my staircase being like
this
this is uh
interesting
all right good great that was fun glad
that happened thank you for that
oh good
looks like a hallway there are drawings
all over the walls greed
looks like a door
but it's just drying or is it though
or is it though
okay to the kitchen i was hungry
hey something's cooking
looks like it needs a serious cleanup
though
microwave shield shut the buttons don't
move in fact the door isn't even real
it's a big plastic box
weird cupboard won't budge an inch
something barricading shut from the
inside
there's a massive iron pot on the oven
looks heavy the paw is boiling violently
you can occasionally feel tiny flex of
scalding hot water try and turn off the
heat but nothing seems to happen remove
the lid
seems ready baby unless i eat some
dinner
ah my eyes
your delicate fingers are no match for
red hot metal the heat makes you drop
the heavy lid immediately and the entire
pot collapses straight onto you the
burns are so serious you can't even get
yourself up from the ground your
agonizing death takes hours and hours
and hours but don't worry
try again tomorrow okay fine thank you
for that i i appreciate that i am dead i
know i am very i get that
we'll see bear but there's a lighter
right in the back pick it up always
handy
all right there's nothing in the fridge
it's not even turned on there's a
lingering scent of expired food
all right do i have anything that could
plunger
plunge it
i can't believe that worked you firmly
test the plunger and remove the heavy
lid this plunger has come in so handy
it's come so in handy
i can't believe it the bot is completely
empty inside it's not even wet there's a
tiny gray button at the bottom push the
button
sure
what was that noise sounds like it came
from under the sink
time to
check
can't even see the back of the cupboard
you don't know how deep it goes in fact
it looks quite roomy in there i'm inside
seems cozy
cozy
oh god
there's a familiar smell coming from the
oven how familiar
fridge door is missing but there's a
thick ice covering inside there's also a
spatula in there frozen solid you can
possibly pull it out by hand well good
thing i have a lighter to melt it off
i'm dead now
the smell
oh
right
ah
all right going into the other kitchen
the under kitchen
oven door is completely stuck you can't
get it open there's an unpleasant smell
coming from inside it's recognizable you
can't put your finger on it seems to be
working just fine though turn on the
oven
i'm not hungry hang on hold on plunger
to the rescue again
but it won't quite stick properly
despite your best efforts it just pops
off ah
come on
and it's empty needs serious cleaning
though
looks like a door but it's just
interesting
all right so i gotta find a way to get
that oven off or else imma go kablooey
imma go real kablooey i know how to do
it
ah
what can i go back
why can't i go back
[Music]
what if i microwave the watering can
okay fine what what
what
why can't i go back okay so i must have
what i need then
melt the ice with some water but it's
too cold to make a difference i'm just
adding more ice okay
okay pry it out
scraping this is the way at the ice
until eventually okay well that makes
sense that makes a lot more sense than
me trying to melt it
not gonna lie that makes that makes
sense
can i leave now
[Music]
need to try and force it in ah this is
gonna create a spark isn't it needs
elbow grease come on all right
i thought so i've got him over here did
i even oh i have the spatula oh that's
how i leave
oh wait a minute
[ __ ]
what is this all about
okay it must be something in here there
must be because the doors are now all
just drawings
so there's got to be a way
let me spatulate
this makes sense that makes a lot of
sense
that makes sense with a bit of force you
manage to pry the stiff oven door open
there's a sudden powerful stench of gas
okay you feel light-headed oven
stretches back in the darkness keeps
going for a while looks let me figure
out how to turn it off first i probably
should get rid of the gas
[Music]
never mind i can't use any more items on
it pretty sure people die from
this
all right let's go nice and warm
you know all the gases make you very
sleepy you try to carry on by feeling
dizzy and sluggish
push on
shake it off yeah exactly it'd be stupid
not to you can hear something moving in
the dark what do you mean heavy chains
blocking the first door they're attached
what
was that
oh my god
nothing
but i kept there looking at the fridge
i meant to use the darkness here feels
strange invasive threatening you can't
even see the hand in front of your face
you couldn't even begin to guess what
horrors could be lurking all around you
but something somewhere decide to
quickly take advantage of the situation
the european shreds in a frenzy you feel
them laughing as they scrape your bones
clean
don't worry
we'll try again tomorrow
okay here we go okay okay we're doing
this we're gonna light it up
oh yeah
okay good
what what okay good
let's climb in the fridge maybe with a
bit of patience you milk through the
thick wax holding the chains in place
until you can't take the weight of the
metal they fall away unblocking the door
okay
long dark horde uh
no turning back now
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait is
there anything else
wait
oh there was something there was
something else i shouldn't leave yet
there's definitely something else there
there's definitely something else there
what's okay let me check the the
bin is empty okay
nothing happens
okay well okay there was all right there
was nothing there
it would have been really clever for
them to hide something there but
apparently it uh
it wasn't
okay no turning back now
okay perfect i'm sure i'm free from the
danger
okay
looks like a hallway but they're drawing
on the walls
oh
[Music]
i didn't mean to actually
it's even darker down near the portal i
didn't mean to actually just go down
here
fuse box hey
wait a minute it was fused
oh
the basement seems different where's the
boiler yeah good question where's the
bug source that's what's shooting out of
my faucet why would i have any water the
fuse box made a cold heavy metal hangs
from the wall but it doesn't look very
secure first fuse inside
remove it
leave it in
this looks like deadly deadly steam
[Music]
it's a bright red valve rattling loudly
with the intense water pressure of the
pipe tighten it
why not
oh did it not tighten it
loosen it oh
interesting that's what was gushing
ah i see
interesting can't find anything helpful
in the cold metal pipes
i know what i need
i know what i need okay
easy
definitely nothing spooky down here use
fuse
and then voila
and then turn this nope
bright red valve tighten it oh yeah you
know i wonder if there's too much
pressure i wonder if i turn this there's
too much pressure
i feel like at some point here there's
gonna be too much pressure
oh interesting okay well that's passable
definitely passable
bright red valve tighten that okay
i wonder i wonder i wonder
if i loosen that one i bet it oh i bet
it didn't do the other one on the other
side of this one
a little strange a little straight yeah
it didn't okay cool all right cool
cool cool cool tight tight
cool
okay tighten it
interesting
i see
interesting well this looks bad
i don't like my undulating plumbing
okay
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
this is fine
this is definitely fine
okay
that do anything for me
well this still seems to be blocked off
okay so there's got to be some
combination of uh
lucy tidy okay i turned off the one that
was all the way far left or i turned it
back on so there's steam pumping out of
there i had to switch fuses to do that
but for everything from here on
i'm not 100 sure about so that one
definitely turns that one off this one
definitely turns this one off this one
is just
procedural so i can get through that
that's fine then i can re-tighten this
one re-loosen that one that'll start
blasting there
this is fine here and then this switch
is that
the left one
and then it's clear
oh some kind of thick sealed jar resting
on top of a wooden stool the sticky
black substance tricks solely from the
smells unpleasantly sleek oh pleasantly
sleepy you pleasantly sweet you're
pleasantly sweet you have no idea what
could be inside take it with you oh yeah
i came all this way so why not
now i just gotta get back out of here
great
good what does this even do
what would be even the point of that and
from here it's just i leave right
i think so i should even be able to take
this fuse with me
i don't really know why
but i have it well that was a fun
excursion
i don't know why i did that
but i now i have a strange jar of goop
and you all know how much i love a
strange jar of goop
really good for me
really good for me
all right door to the living room
front door but it's just a drawing
that's a little weird
okay all right then fine i'll go to the
living room
[Music]
oh god
oh my god
shelves are bear hanging uncomfortably
from the sky with hooks and chains
great
my trophy
looks like you could unhook it with ease
if only you could reach it all right uh
what's with all the chains
arm tear is suspended by change you're
not sure what the chains are hanging
from you can't even see the ceiling
there if there even is one you give it a
firm tug but it doesn't budge
okay
cool knife yeah that's trustworthy large
knife on the table sharpens stuck deep
in the wood remove it i like it sharp
i got a knife
oh god
oh god
a series of mechanical shutters you hear
scurrying noise coming from upstairs who
knows what it could have been
your head hurts you're starting to feel
sleepy well i'm glad i went through this
endeavor
[Music]
i don't like this place very much
i'll go upstairs
sure
let's ascend
i think i got everything that i needed
oh good there's an x on my door
oh god there's an x in my room
you can hear a noise but it sounds
muffled oh no
oh no
oh no the lump in my bed has evolved
like a pokemon i'll just save my game
here
and uh
stab a boo
oh yeah stab
that's what you get what you get this is
what you get this is what you deserve
this is what you deserve this is what
you deserve
that was messy it looks like the lump
isn't a problem anymore well good
yeah take that knife
not sure why i did that
although there was a lot of resistance
and a lot of this thick black sludge
could have couldn't can't have done the
blade any favors you might want to check
on your knife
i might want a what
what
what
1 9 19.
19 also strange jar
okay sure
okay good maybe i could get this uh
photograph off
is far too dull and warped to be any use
why did you think this would be helpful
i mean just look at it i am looking at
it
what more do you want from me i see what
it say
uh fine it no use for anything i get i
get i understand i understand
i stand
it's fine
oh god
[Music]
what's happening it's not just dead
brother you bet no
no what no
what do
what do you mean i abandon it i'll
abandon you
i'll abandon you right now i'll abandon
you instantaneously i'm gonna put a jar
of strange right here
oh yeah
oh yeah that's nice
okay uh-oh
i didn't want to open it i just wanted
to put it there
oh dear so that's what was in the jar
this whole time bees
the jar of angry bees you're a red lumpy
messing minute the pain is so bad it's
almost a relief when you finally
suffocate on your own swollen throat
wow you should really keep that thing
closed i'm kind of more oh you shut your
[ __ ] mouth i
can stab you with this knife stabbed
other things just because it's warped
and covered in sludge doesn't make it's
gonna it doesn't mean it's gonna be any
harder for me to stab you
man i went down to the basement for what
let's get a spatula spatch
it oh i can use the spatula to get the
photograph off
i understand maybe i can use it for this
wow i'm the best
the spatula is freaking amazing
good thing you weren't touching it
burning smell lingers in the air
nice
toothbrush
hell yeah i can finally brush my teeth
that was an objective that was an enough
objective yank it out
oh
well that doesn't sound good what was
that
sounds like it came from the bathroom i
better go check
or maybe i shouldn't yeah let's go for
it
seems quieter now you think
can't hurt what's going on oh
wow
stepping over them is asking for trouble
at least you're wearing shoes
huh
okie dokie then
brush my teeth barely recognize yourself
these days there are deep creases all
over your face sweat and dirt cling to
every crack it's a shameful sight but it
can't be much worse than what's
underneath you might as well try right
scrub-a-dub-dub baby scrub-a-dub-dub i
remember my objectives from the
beginning of this game scrub-a-dub-dub
oh clean or not you're not great to look
at
at least when it was covered in dirt you
had an excuse hey
maybe you shouldn't have bothered at
least you wash your face congratulations
i guess
hey you are an [ __ ] brush my
mouth is dry and fuzzy days of grime
cover your teeth and tongue you really
should sort it out
well i'll do that
why not
why not right
you do the best you can your mouth feels
cleaner but um closer inspection the
rotten decay are so severe it would take
a lot more of the work to fix that mouth
of yours better than nothing i guess
congratulations thank you
thank you very much
i feel very proud of myself although i i
feel like the thing dying was not my
fault
there's a big hole full of wires you
know you can't afford to keep
dismantling your house like this right i
don't even know this is my house man i
really don't know if this is my house
oh wait
i have lighter
yeah light from the flame you can just
about make out what's written on the
notepad but it's nothing useful just a
phallic sketch your name is written
underneath a self-portrait perhaps oh
and the number 57 is written in the
corner but you don't recognize the
handwriting
okay 1957.
i know numbers
you tell me numbers i know numbers
there we go that's what i'm talking
about
with a few firm scrapes you managed to
loosen the photo frame from the shelf
there's a sticky dusty film still on the
bottom photograph of old friends
oh look at that old picture of some
people who used to like you who knows
where they are now oh look at that i'm
gonna put that up in the decoration
place
even though i would have had a flower
there which is kind of bs that is that
that's pretty bs if that counts against
me i'm gonna be pretty pissed
okay well lucky for you
bam
bam
starting to look better but there's
still a lot of space left
as
you know
i bet my trophy would help but
i don't have that okay so now that i
have that
what i'm guessing is i need to get the
it's got to be something to do with this
code like 1957. uh something there
but i don't have anything that could pry
the boards off the storage room but
there is
this trophy that's saying if only i
could get it
i wonder if i could put stuff on the
shelves and maybe it would be like a
counterbalance
nah how about the plunger
how about the spatula
you can just about poke the bottom you
need something even longer to get that
thing down
how about
the
rubbish
[Music]
what else is there
[Music]
see what's on
channel 19.
that's handy oh look it's your front
door key must have fallen from the sky
apparently
there's also a giant chair above my head
don't think i don't see the sofa that's
about to drop on my nog if i don't get
the right channel but i do also have
a different channel
uh
57.
oh
baby
[Music]
oh
okay okay well something opened up
outside i'm just double checking
everything here but something definitely
opened up outside but what did is the
question
what did this is the front door but it's
just a drawing
but it it the tv showed
another door
[Music]
with like a light on it it wasn't this
one
the strange material seems thinner here
like it's coming away from the walls
scrape it off
[Music]
spatula is really useful man the special
is the ultimate tool
can i use that on any door nah
all right door somewhere
oh something smells delicious
good
so i see the crumpled piece of paper
through the oven door
clean it up i guess
it's crawled note
0-1 okay
something squirming inside some kind of
blue squirming mass you couldn't guess
what it is but it smells fantastic
it seems to be working fine turn on
let's get cooking
19 minutes and 57
seconds
didn't do anything okay
one minute
one second
is that what it was
one
it must be one minute because the one
piece of paper must be the this must be
the minutes and then the other one would
be like the seconds
i get it try 157.
nah
it's definitely probably not probably
not
yeah
it's definitely one minute and something
what was this oh it's your key oh it
seems different somehow you're probably
just imagining things yeah take the key
seems different somehow
[Music]
pretty flimsy spatula come to think of
it you probably shouldn't bother give it
a shot
fine
are you wasting your time
[Music]
wait what
for all that effort you're quite
exhausted maybe you should take a rest
watch some television have a nice sit
down you can always head outside later
wait
but
[Music]
what
what
i'm trying to remember why you ever
wanted to leave and frankly you can't
think of a reason you should stay inside
what
i need to leave
you slide the key in the lock and turn
it with a click your head hurts the door
is unlocked you don't want to go outside
you want to stay here
what
well
the door is unlocked looks like it's
time for some lovely fresh air you know
it certainly is cozy in here why would
you ever want to go outside anyway
what
really you still want to go outside
i need to get out
look you don't know what you're thinking
clearly you're confused it's been an
awfully difficult day you need to rest
you need to lie down your hair is a
total mess you haven't eaten that thing
don't go outside maybe try again
tomorrow when you're feeling better my
hair's a mess and i haven't eaten
anything and i know that there's
something to eat there but also i'm kind
of curious what happens if you're just
if i just bolt out the door
wait please
just think about this you can't leave
you're not ready to leave you have
nothing you are nothing there's nothing
for you out there this is your home it's
where you belong don't go outside
it's time to leave
that doesn't look like fresh air
i didn't look like fresh air
oh
oh god
[Music]
oh dear
that didn't go very well did it at least
you tried
not that it's worse than anything you
can't say i didn't warn you
oh
well okay all right then maybe some
things just aren't that simple don't
worry try again tomorrow
eat my ass
ray nothing happened
well
that's it
that's the game hope it wasn't too
disappointing let's see how you did
shall we
wait a minute succumbed to 10 of 20
possible threats and found 17 to 26
items you wasted 18 hours playing video
games you didn't even beat your high
score
curiosity gets you killed by swarm beans
you put up one decoration but it still
looks pretty shabby in here you put up
one decoration but still looks pretty
shabby you failed to keep a single plane
alive i was
i didn't know that it would die you
didn't find the secret anger you were
lazy took your long time to get this far
you can't have been trying very hard you
were reckless you really didn't think
things through did you
wonder you made it this far at all you
were stupid some might call it
creativity most wouldn't
you tried a lot of a lot of ideas but
none of them were good basically you're
not a good person and everything you've
done is pointless i guess this just
isn't a very happy ending but thanks for
playing well eat
my
whole ass
you think that you can just talk to me
like that
no way in hell am i gonna tolerate any
of that [ __ ] because that's all that
is 100
[ __ ]
which it is and which you are
so shut up you shut in i'm gonna come
back and i'm gonna kick your ass from
here tuesday which is
four days from now so freak you i'll be
right back i need to backtrack a bit all
right it's day two of this [ __ ] and i'm
going back and what that means is i'm
going back
and i'm gonna retrace my steps because
this game's an [ __ ] and i'm not gonna
let it talk down to me
you know what i mean
you alright little buddy
all right it's okay
recently been watered okay so it's fine
for now it'll need watering soon-ish i
don't remember where because i wasn't
exactly saving in the right order that i
should have been doing things but that
doesn't matter because i'm going to be
fine so i think what i need to do is i
need to descend
i need to descend down here and then i
go down yep descend
easy
easy peasy
so i go in the kitchen i don't be stupid
i need a item to pry this off the
plunger
nice
wait i need the lighter
[Music]
that's right
okay so i got this what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna go straight back up to the
plant because i'm pretty sure that it
was pretty close
to needing more wabber
so i'ma go wobber it
and it better not be dead if it's dead
i'm gonna be pissed
no weird
all right fine then i guess i'm just
moving too quick for you now i'm gonna
go do the basement of boiler room stuff
get the
bucket of bees
down in the basement all right this is
easy this one super easy all right i
have the bees seems useful all right i
have the bees and then i'm going right
up to the plant
because i ain't gonna let it die
or maybe i've already let it die because
it was just about to not die and then
i'm gonna be real pissed you better be
alive in there that's all i gotta say
about that
excellent that's what we love to see
that's what we wanna see yeah i know i
know
yeah there we go nice
check up on it later absolutely
absolutely i'll do that all right cool
cool cool cool cool cool hey the knife
that's right the knife is here yeah
let's see what's on
57
okay i have the can of bees i've got
half of the note that i need i've got a
knife that i need to go stab someone
with they're just asking for a stabbing
hello friend
i believe it alone i'm a save and then
i'ma smack that ass so hard
oh i'm gonna smack the [ __ ] out of that
ass oops
i meant to smack it i think i poked it
i meant to smack it
ah
i was gonna smack that ass oh
good
i was gonna smack dash
smack it hard
whap
now we may continue
after i have smacked that ice
all right now i'm gonna stab that ass
i'm gonna tear that ice into ace hole
wham
that's what you get 19 again all right i
now know 19. i'm gonna check on the
plant just in case
just in case like its progress has
accelerated at all oh my god it did
oh
[Music]
yeah sure why not
[Music]
huh
getting pretty out of control surely it
can't get much bigger than this should
check up on it later that's fine
it's definitely fine let's do the
bathroom stuff scrub a dub dub
okay i'm scrubbed
my bathroom is gonna be scrubbed nope
hang on my my teeth
my teeth are gonna be scrubbed nice oh
let me try something else i want to try
something um this this photograph is
pretty dirty can i clean it
ah nah it's okay
okay so it's ready i just didn't know if
it was supposed to be cleaned if it
would get a bonus point for that or
something okay now i need to do channel
19.
[Music]
okay i got that key great so i do need
to find a way to get that thing out like
down
i don't know just yet i just want to
make sure there's nothing else here
[Music]
that i need to do
okay
didn't i get my key off the ground
somehow how did that happen i remember i
threw my key down wait did i not oh i
didn't throw my key down right oh [ __ ]
is that gonna bite my ass is that gonna
bite my ass
is my key down here now
ah there it is
seems different somehow i'll take the
key i'm gonna use this key on my room
because it seems it said it seems
different now
so i'm gonna do it on the room now that
it's different now
oh door somehow it keeps turning ah
there's a loud click oh unlock the
unlocked door
oh
wow
okay
oh my goodness
oh my goodness oh wow
okay
interesting
weird
oh
fun
very fun
those chains look different
[Music]
climb the chain
okay oh
oh what's this
ah a note
this is the other half of the
ah minute 34 the perfect cooking time we
all know this to be true it's getting
darker oh my god it's getting darker
again
[Music]
oh
oh boy
um
[Music]
who knows how long you spend wandering
the corridor hours days weeks this isn't
even a room anymore it's just a roomy
coffin your death is slow and worst of
all
boring
don't worry
all right cool thanks man hey
i'm dead
at least i know the number now
i've gone too far you're right i've gone
too far
so once i get that i need to go back
don't remember how caught your head is
pounding
you're right
i have the note
right oh right
i have to find my way out
interesting
right
oh i needed to like use the key on the
door didn't i okay yeah that's probably
what i needed to do i needed to use the
key on the door
and that would have gotten me out of
there so it's like no matter what you
would die by getting this i think that's
kind of like the idea
unless i'm completely wrong which i
might be i might be very wrong all right
let's try this
yep here we go
nice
nice let's check on the plant let's
check on this plant
oh my god
totally out of control let alone every
now and then there you swear you can see
it move an enormous colorful flower
hangs friends of eyes remove it
sure
freshly picked flower wow
cutting the flower must have caused a
lot of damage going black around a
severed stem
maybe i can water it again
nope no watering all right well thank
you for the flower
i think this goes in the vos right here
[Music]
huh grew with your own hands
well that's nice
[Music]
that's nice
huh
how about i put the painting
yeah
oh
starting to look a little better but
there's still a lot of space off i'm
betting i get the trophy from the thing
and then maybe some like books or
something i have no idea there's still
the thing about that wooden box but i'm
gonna come back to that once i have a
little bit more i'm making good progress
now i am making actual progress now
and i appreciate this game trying to
harass me and me not allowing it that's
what i appreciate
hey wait what the hell
oh
somebody left a hairbrush on the floor
it's not yours or at least you don't
recognize it yoink
all right i'll go brush my hair i guess
we love a hairbrush
[Music]
it's not a pretty sight your dense mess
of hair is getting out of control hey
that's part of my charm you try to fix
it but you doubt it'll do much good
brush your hair
why not
why not also shut up
well that sounds painful oh look at my
hair well it's certainly a change you
look tidier now
at the very least it's not a huge
improvement
but it's better than nothing it's an
improvement no matter what small baby
steps hey towards the glorious me that
is me
you can shut up and watch me be
beautiful
i brush my hair shame about that face
though you know shame about your whole
existence though you know it's a shame
that you are who you are
all right let's go let's go my friends
let's go
i've got something to cook
let's get cooking
1 34.
nice
that smell is getting stronger cold dark
and empty remind you of anyone yeah you
you soulless bastard
stop trying to talk [ __ ] about me i'm
too amazing incredible aroma is making
your head span
i wonder if i should be here for it
barely stand this hunger you need to eat
well i'm about to in however many 14
seconds i don't know
[Music]
oh well that's fun
sounds like you finished cooking
that was the longest minute 34 of your
life you're right it was
it's exquisite unlike anything you've
ever experienced you can't stop
salivating the lump has stopped moving
mostly
bon appetit
[Music]
eh
you've had better
but at least you ate something whatever
something means congratulations thank
you i appreciate that well now would you
look at that haven't you done well
you're clean clothed and fed ready to
get some lovely fresh air there's
nothing stopping you now no more excuses
it's time to head outside
i've already devoured the contents of
the microwave like a fat greedy pig and
now you want seconds control yourself
well you know how it is what's with the
goop
i can't use anything on it okay so
there's gotta be one more step for
the room upstairs right
there's definitely something else going
on let me go save something might have
changed up here who knows a lot of
things have been changing randomly so
this it's got to be something about the
storage room right so something i have
must work for that
plunger
this doesn't make a lot of sense but i
don't care i'm not gonna worry about it
i'm just gonna do
completely empty inside what a
ridiculous weight of waste of time well
maybe not
okay i can't use anything more on it
an empty wooden crate looks just about
big enough for a person about your size
climb inside perfect fit
nice
it's more comfortable than you thought
there's even a room to shut the box
completely close the lid i'm not gonna
well okay i am gonna shut it i'm gonna
shut it because i have items that i
didn't have before when i did this and i
think this is part of it you close it
but then maybe it's like dark so
[Music]
start to feel different
i'm gonna use peace and quiet
[Music]
yeah
so i'm gonna use this
use a lighter
[Music]
i knew it i knew it box is bigger than
you thought you can't see the end
you're right
oh hell yeah
oh hell yeah
hell yeah
hell yeah who
maybe not hell no hell no hell no oh
hell no
oh no
hell no
what is that small box on the ground
wrapped up with a shiny bow a lot of
effort must have gone into it couldn't
possibly do yours i mean nobody would
bother working this hard to make you
some make someone like you feel special
hey i'm loved by many people
and i have many friends so you shut your
[ __ ] mouth
pick it up it's pretty
obtained gift from a loved one you're
damn right it is oh
okay
i should run i should run i should get
out i'm trying to i don't exactly know
how
but uh
oh
well that's not good
okay what could i possibly do to get out
okay never mind
i'm trapped in a box well you're still
alive not that you tried very hard you
really don't move very fast do you shame
you're still trapped in this box
the sides of the box are sturdy as ever
okay what about screwdriving
okay
oh
oh
weird oh look you're back in the house
it was probably nicer in the box
interesting a crowber wow this thing
would really been helpful to open that
box oh well take it with you better late
than never or a hell yeah because i'm
gonna crowbar open this
that's where there's a crowbar in like
every one of these games okay crowbar
use it
love it live it life it
please tell me there's like a step
ladder or like a long pole
[Music]
i'm in
eventually managed to pry the last of
the soggy wood away from the door frame
most of it was so brittle that it felt
the pieces in your hands trying awfully
hard to get in this room but there must
have been a reason it was locked up in
the first place right yeah probably shut
up
oh
messing here you feel like you're being
watched
oh and there's also some objects on the
floor ah
you dick shut up
okay dozens of boxes and a heaving pile
blocking your way you'll have to clean
them up if you want to get past sounds
too much like hard work really clear the
boxes
[Music]
fine
what a drag
and that's what i'm all about sometimes
you got to clean things out
i think i get what this game is trying
to say and i think you guys do too
like it's understandable and i i do get
it and i i kind of like it i don't like
what they're saying to me but it's it's
like a lesson right this is kind of
representative of what people go through
and that's what the developer went
through you know keep folding up boxes
but you swear they just come and keep
coming back this rate you'll be here
forever keep trying
stick with it
stick with it
whatever
you finally managed to fold up the last
of the boxes tidying them away in the
side of the room you already feel tired
well hello
i'm very exciting ah that eye though an
easel and canvas with an unfinished
painting you're not sure what it's
supposed to be but it has potential
maybe you should finish it do some
painting
yeah why not oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh
is it like an scp anywhere oh god
they're not sure what's hiding beyond
those walls but you know they're
watching you judging you the moment
you're distracted they take advantage of
deciding upon you in a violent rage you
wish you had a better idea of who they
are what they wanted or even what they
did to you clearly you weren't paying
much attention you'd really stay focused
but don't worry try again tomorrow
thank you
[Music]
thank you thank you
take this opportunity to say pay
attention well you know whatever
man
i thought it was supposed to be a
creative endeavor that was going to help
me along
cheap rickety old chair looks like an
antique though not very impressive one
cushion seats you're tired after moving
all those boxes
ah not darn
darts oh hell yeah
looks functional play some darts not
tired
ah large toy chest from your childhood
makes you feel upset most of the stuff
inside of broken but you find your old
funtendo gameplay
oh what a classic nah come on
not gonna trick me
box is a brick-a-brack on the shelf they
don't seem useful it makes a mess you
find a bunch of souvenirs they need to
clean but it looks like they make good
decorations i will
come back to them
hmm
[Music]
a few broken cleaning and sporting use
implements tune around the mostly useful
old dumbbell exercise
already too tired okay
old childhood toy might even be worth
something if weren't completely broken
at least it still looks good
nowhere to put it
[Music]
important looking papers and boxes of
documents stacking your way you need to
organize them but there's nowhere to put
all this stuff there must be some way to
make space in here okay yeah um
hold on now
shiny okay all right we're okay
we're okay
we're okay
all right take it with me
okay all right we're fine
okay do i have a do some filing
fine true i guess
where do you even start this is going to
take a long time it sure is sometimes
this stuff takes a long time especially
if it's piled up after a while
i get it
i get it oh look while sorting through
your papers you stumble across one of
your old school books
give them a read
stay focused
is this ever gonna end
oh you find a bunch of unopened letters
that you never noticed before they look
important read them
[Music]
investigate
oh no no come on oh come on my add brain
you can't blame me
i should have known i should have known
i shouldn't
ignore them carefully organized all your
old papers and pack them neatly away
onto shelves how boring i know
well this is strange
what's over here
it's a pile of useless broken junk
pathetic really no well shut
up a huge set of fabric curtains are
draped over a dusty window so they're
completely blocking all the light there
must be a window behind there really
ready it's time for light
take this eyeballs
oh that's not a window
oh there's no window behind the curtains
but there's a large painting on the wall
it reminds you of something painful from
long ago take the painting
let's redecorate
wow
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh they're not happy
they aren't happy not happy
or not happy i'm sorry i'll leave okay
goodbye
okay
well i have a lot of things i could
possibly uh put on the walls here
let's do the uh forgotten souvenirs
[Music]
yeah
that'll look nice hmm a lot of space
left but i've got a lot of things to
fill it
let's see what
happens oh that's cute still room for
more how about a painting of outside
[Music]
that's nice a few decorations still room
for more i bet the trophy
and maybe something else i have no idea
but now that i have the crowbar i think
that i can go downstairs and get the
trophy from the which is it because i
know that i could go outside but it's
clearly they said that there was a
secret ending and obviously that means
that i need to find it
you know what i mean
you know what i mean
crowbar trophy yeah you know
unrecognizable trophy
i got it good what do i do with the bees
what am i to do with the bees i have
many bees
and i don't know what to do with bees
unless it's to sting eyes out or
something like that i have no idea
bees do love flowers maybe i was
supposed to use it on the flower i don't
know the air is almost fully deserted
but still missing something all right
what is it missing if i go back in here
am i gonna die
what happens if i use the bees in here
i'm gonna use the bees
don't feel welcome in here anymore
well
shut up huh okay
so it's definitely not here
take a seat have a break
let's see how it feels maybe it'll give
me a hint
hmm it's nice i guess it's missing
something
yeah it is missing something
could do with some more decorations yeah
well i'm trying
[Music]
now but a tangled mass of withered dry
vines
i can't use anything on it i doubt that
there would be anything left i doubt
that 01 and 34 are
channels
there's no way
this is going to drop that on my head i
know that
there's no way
yeah i thought so i thought so i thought
so i thought so
found a place to sit here i found you
bones are bounded to dust you don't
remember your couch being so heavy but
don't worry dragon tomorrow okay
so there's gotta be
some males
the gift wait oh i forgot about the gift
holy crap i'm an idiot it was in my
pocket
[Music]
and now fully decorated almost feels
cozy congratulations
let's take a seat
[Music]
you know what
it does feel cozy in here
it was a lot of hard work but you made
things a little bit better you didn't
get any fresh air
oh maybe that's fine at least for today
it's time for a rest
fascinating
you're never happy are you
wait
okay i have to save because i made it
better in and i'm almost positive this
is how it is this this house isn't
really a house so much as it's a
representative of my own mind
and like the clutter is is not so much
i mean it is like the clutter in my
exterior and exterior environment but
it's also the clutter that's inside my
own mind and it is difficult when you
have a voice in your head that is
telling you all these negative things
but like even if even if okay i have to
see okay let me check at procedurally i
think that this is the wrong choice
first but i have saved here
so i think that this is not the correct
choice to get the
the final ending but i'm gonna do this
just because
it's uh
right here
a job well done this is probably gonna
lead to some kind of an ending but i
don't know if this is the
right ending you know what i mean i
still have this jar of bees why do i
have a jar of bees it may not be much
but it's
something oh that's cute
but there's still bars well that's it
that's the game hope it wasn't too
disappointing let's see how you did
i found 26 of 26 items so that's good
i unlocked the secret ending but chose
not to accept it
see that's what i thought because the
truth is like you got to take care of
what's in your head number one
clean up some of the decrease that's
built up and that takes work that takes
a lot of work and it's not fun
but also you know that's not the last
step
because you know you got to take care of
the exterior too
yes
yes i know it's fine
i need to leave
[Music]
you slide the key into the lock and turn
it with a click your head hurts the door
is unlocked you don't want to go outside
you want to stay here no i don't
i want to go outside well
the door is unlocked looks like it's
time for some lovely fresh air
you know it certainly is cozy in here
why would you ever want to go outside
anyway
[Music]
really
you still want to go outside i need to
get out
look
you don't know what you're thinking
clearly you're confused it has been an
awfully difficult day you need rest you
need to lie down don't go outside maybe
try again tomorrow when you're feeling
better
let me out that's the thing
it's it's the days when you're not
feeling great that you really gotta push
through like it's easy on days when you
feel fine
it's easy
it's hard when you're not
please just think about this you can't
leave you're not ready you have nothing
you are nothing there's nothing for you
out there that's where you're wrong it's
time to leave
you know what you've done so well you've
really made an effort had some food put
on some clothes cleaned up yourself
today was a good day you should be proud
he deserves something special you
deserve a good ending
don't go outside head back upstairs and
go to bed that's where the secret ending
is the real ending
the happy ending
no
i don't believe you let me out
[Music]
you sack of [ __ ]
you sack a [ __ ] you sack of [ __ ]
you
sack of [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's dumb
um
i'm trying not to be too upset about it
but it's fine because it's very counter
to what i believe would be the correct
answer in that case and this better just
be a purely story based thing
you know what i mean it better be purely
story based or i'm gonna have some
sharsh words to say
whatever whatever
all right today was a good day you
should be proud you deserve something
special you deserve a good ending don't
go outside head back upstairs and go to
bed that's where the secret ending is
the real ending the happy ending how
exciting okay
i'm going upstairs
to the secret ending
i can't wait
i am so excited
ah interesting
i feel safe here
for some reason
hmm
interesting where's my alarm clock
my bed it never looks so soft so warm
you've earned a rest go to sleep
let's end this
congratulations
you did it
you've won
you finally got some fresh air
ah how peaceful
no fear
no stress
no pain
you're free well done
you've earned this rest don't think
about tomorrow just enjoy the moment
[Music]
well
that's it
that's the game hope it wasn't too
disappointing let's see how you did
tagged 12 times found all items wasted
nine hours
what
were the bees for
hold on finding the secret ending most
people wouldn't have bothered i guess
more people have better things to do i
was lazy
what were the bees
for not a good person and everything
you've done is pointless but
at least you took care of yourself for
today anyway congratulations try again
tomorrow thanks for playing
something else is going on here
there's no way if that is then fine but
also come on but hold on hey hold on
i've not gone through this game twice
now to deal with jo
hold on
four endings four four
four
four what are the b's for
what are the bees for what are they for
tell me what the bees are about tell me
what the bees are for there's something
else here because it doesn't like it
doesn't gel right it doesn't it doesn't
gel with me that the answer of the
secret ending is just like that it's
it's not i bet i bet there's something
about it where if you do everything
perfectly with no deaths that there's
some other ending to get because going
outside is clearly the objective that is
clearly the objective that was this that
might have been the secret ending but it
may it was not the good ending right
because the whole crux of this this game
and it may just be like cosmic surreal
or like it's depressing and it's meant
to be and that's fine but the lesson to
be learned from it is that like people
can get locked in their own heads in
depressive cycles and stuff like that
and things can feel insurmountable and
they build up over a long period of time
and then they become insurmountable and
it's only through great effort
incredible consistent effort on a daily
basis to climb out of the hole that
you've fallen into to even have a chance
of getting that breath of fresh air like
it's a long journey and you have no idea
where the top is but it only is through
consistent effort that you can get there
and the whole point is like
maybe that's the lesson to be learned
about this is that like if there is that
good ending and it's about playing
perfectly from start to finish then
maybe
then maybe
that's how you get the good ending is
because the lesson isn't so much the
game ended there tomorrow is another
opportunity to try to be perfect in this
game and i could do that and i could
play this game in an attempt to be
perfect about it it's kind of like that
journey of perfection of lessons learned
you you learn the things that get in
your way about how they stop you and
prevent you from doing things perfectly
but you still make progress to get that
kind of like perfect day and i mean
perfection is a goal that you should
never aim for because it's something
that can't be achieved but you know in
this game representatively i would
imagine that's what it's talking about
and probably holding on to the the the
trash
maybe not the best idea
i don't have time for this uh in this
episode if there is something else there
i kind of want you guys to explore it
there's a link in the description
that'll get you to this game this was
very fun like i thought it was a great
experiment and it always kept me chasing
after it and i liked that about games i
just wanted to get the right answer
because it's a puzzle clearly it's a
puzzle but like when it comes down to
mental illness it's not really a puzzle
it's an individual like thing it's an
introspective
journey you know you gotta you gotta
feel it out through yourself and clear
the clutter that's in your own head so
anyway hope you enjoyed this this was
kind of like a whirlwind of a game i did
love it though and that's why i think
that there's something more to this it
said there were four endings in the last
update that came out and i only got two
of them there's a good ending out there
and i think it might be just like
playing perfectly i could try but i just
don't have time right now
so thank you let me know what you
thought down in the comments below and
as always i will see you
in the next video
bye
[Music]